the Ferrari 308 GTS this has to beat the
most iconic all the Ferraris introduced
in 1977 at the Frankfurt Auto Show this
one is in the correct color course it
has to be red some really nice details
like the targa top here that lifts out
the original period features on it this
one's in 1978 and it even has the
charging port this car was rebuilt from
a burnt-out wreck the v8 engine was
destroyed when a fuel leak caught fire
but that didn't matter to Ferrari fan
Eric Hutchinson we found this car at the
junkyard with a salvage title completely
burned up from a fuel leak we picked it
up for about 10 grand brought it home
and decided to work on the conversion
project what better way than give it
life then put our electric motors double
down on the power and make one heck of a
performance machine out of this car
Ferrari boss Sergio Marchionne a once
said an electric Ferrari is an obscene
concept well this is what obscene looks
like
there's a trio of electric motors belted
together and a 30 kilowatt hour battery
pack spread between here in the back and
up front they mean the car can now
travel about 80 miles on pure strangely
silent electric power it maintains a
similar front about weight distribution
as the original mid-engine car and
better still at only a hundred pounds
heavier it's quick it has that awesome
instantly available torque that electric
motors give 330 foot pounds of it versus
the original 179 what's really neat
about this car is that we were able to
put in a G 50 and use the manual stick
shift that came with the Porsche
transmission this car models out at
8,000 rpms at 84 miles per hour in
second gear Hutchinson wants to do some
upgrades before doing an instrument at 0
to 60 but it's likely to be under 5
seconds that's faster than the old v8
and even when it's stationary an
electric Ferrari certainly adds some fun
to the typical lineup of plug-in
vehicles while you still won't be able
to buy one from the factory perhaps this
car may change ma kione's mind about
electric Ferraris